Tough times sometimes call for tough measures.
Since MGM announced that No Time to Die was
pushing its April 2020 release date back to
November due to concerns about the coronavirus
outbreak, film exhibitors everywhere have
grown nervous about when and where the other
shoe will drop.
It's rather a lose-lose situation as it stands
right now, no matter what route is chosen,
as U.S. theater patronage could possibly fall
precipitously by the time the next major blockbuster
release, Black Widow, is slated to arrive
in theaters.
The current conversation regarding potential
release date delays has some speculating that
Disney and Marvel Studios will push the film
from its scheduled May 1 debut, according
to Deadline. The outlet notes that, quote,
"it wouldn't be jawdropping if Disney decides
to move Black Widow," but there are some tricky
logistics to discuss. Sounds like a real party,
huh?
"I — I don't see how that's a party."
Asian market box office revenue is important
to the franchise's success, and the coronavirus
situation in China and Korea in particular
is especially concerning for turnout. However,
moving the release of Black Widow in hopes
of deferring interruption by the coronavirus
is an expensive and potentially confusing
effort for the consumer base that may not
be paying attention to shifts in the film
release schedule and may not show up when
the new release date comes around. The coronavirus
has the potential to be a seasonal event like
influenza, even though time will certainly
provide more treatment options while global
efforts work hard to find them. One exhibitor
was quoted by Deadline as saying, "we are
in uncharted territory.".
So far, Disney has decided to stay its course
for Black Widow's May 1 release date. A Bond
movie changing release date is a big deal,
what with the guaranteed glitz and glamour
of a red carpet party attached to every continental
premiere, but No Time to Die isn't the marketing
behemoth that any Marvel Cinematic Universe
movie is.
Yes, Black Widow was a surprise inclusion
to the expanding post-Avengers: Endgame universe,
given that the character died during Endgame
after throwing herself off the cliff in Vormir
in order for her fellow Avenger Hawkeye to
obtain the Soul Stone and undo the events
of Avengers: Infinity War. But no MCU film
release is just about the movie. It's also
about expensive brand tie-ins, like putting
Black Widow actress Scarlett Johansson on
soda cans and Dorito chip bags. It's about
toys. It also involves the rest of Marvel's
Phase 4 movie schedule inching along behind
it.
In other words, Black Widow is more than just
a single movie right now, it's the first car
of a whole train, staring down an economic
hazard that has potential to cause a major
derailment. In that sense, it might be safer
to just release the movie as planned, and
deal with screening it in empty theaters while
hoping to recoup costs via other avenues later.
Another thing worth noting which might indicate
Black Widow sticking to its planned release
date is that Disney and Marvel Studios can
take a financial hit in a way MGM just can't.
No Time to Die will probably be MGM's biggest
box office draw of the year, and the possibility
of releasing it in China specifically when
quarantines and mandatory self-isolation orders
are in effect means guaranteed major financial
loss. Disney faces similar difficulty in releasing
internationally, but it's also a vastly larger
corporation than MGM, with plenty of other
major releases set to come out over the rest
of the year including, of course, the other
major MCU release, The Eternals.
In related recent news, Marvel Studios has
halted production on its Disney+ series The
Falcon and the Winter Soldier due to coronavirus
concerns. The show, which stars Anthony Mackie
and Sebastian Stan in the title roles, was
filming in Prague at the time of the production
shutdown. According to Deadline, The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier had moved production
from Atlanta to the European country for a
"short shoot" that began on Friday, March
6, and was expected to be completed in around
one week. On Wednesday, March 11, Marvel executives
sent everyone out of Prague and back to Atlanta,
with the chances of returning to Prague to
finish the shoot apparently seeming unlikely.
The good news is that Disney and Marvel have
the freedom to put off their unfinished projects
without too much concern for major consequences;
in the case of Black Widow, it's understandable
that the studios would want to stick to the
plan.
All studios are likely going to wince and
preemptively tighten the projected earning
belt buckle this year due to the coronavirus
outbreak, but at this point in time, there's
no real reason to worry about Black Widow's
fate. Whatever happens, we're sure we'll see
it eventually.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon. Subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one.